hey guys welcome to another episode of
the Wednesday checkup before we get to
the topic at hand which is kovin 19 we
have to address the protests currently
going on and the murder of George Floyd
at the hands of police I wholeheartedly
with every ounce of my being denounced
and condemned racism of any kind
especially to those of the black
community at the hands of police racism
isn't just a human rights issue it's
also a health issue your zip code says
more about how long you live and the
quality of life you live more than your
cholesterol score and that's a huge
problem in our nation and it needs to be
addressed know that I stand in firm
support in solidarity with those who are
protesting these racial and Justices in
fact I heard a really great speech the
other day by killer Mike and I'm gonna
be linking it to my end card check it
out for sure at the end of this video
speaking of video I once again have to
point out that I'm disappointed in our
nation's media at a time where we need
unity they're sowing seeds of divisive
'no star only highlighting the protests
when they get violent they're not
showing the countless individuals that
are out there there are protecting
themselves by socially distancing
wearing masks being responsible and
being peaceful there are plenty of these
examples but they are a far and fewer
between on our media channels and that's
a problem we need to be able to trust
the media to tell us the truth so that
we can make better decisions for
ourselves and our families to sum up my
message black lives matter
and speaking of black lives mattering
something that has given me concerned
worried about black lives is the fact
that so many black communities are out
there protesting because they have to at
a time of a pandemic where they're not
only putting their lives on the line
because of police injustice but also
because of this virus and Kovan 19 has
already dramatically and drastically
affected communities of color
disproportionately in comparison to
other communities so I worry and I hope
that the masks the social distancing
measures the hand-washing is going to be
enough to protect these communities if
you choose to go out and protest please
do your best to do it safely and if you
have someone living with you that's a
potentially high risk over nineteen
patient someone who's over the age of
sixty has an immunocompromised State or
has several other medical conditions
do your best to limit your interaction
with that person to keep them safe as
well let's continue this conversation
about kovat 19 because people are still
getting sick with it and at the same
time we need to begin the reopening of
America because the harms of staying
close are starting to creep up and the
benefits are starting to get limited
plus I'm sure we all want to get
outdoors as the weather improves but we
have to do the going outside and
reopening of America strategically and
smartly so we don't have another
outbreak so we don't have this giant
second wave where thousands died and the
hospital system potentially breaks those
are things we do not want so I thought
during this video I can answer some of
your most common questions about Kovan
19 this summer
what about pools my quick answer to that
is you could absolutely get Cove in 19
while being at a pool what you can't
have happen is to get cove at 19 from
the actual pool water that is if it's
properly maintained if the pool has
proper chlorine levels bromine levels
the CDC has stated that there cannot be
transmission of Cova 19 from the actual
pool water but that doesn't mean if
Bobby or Sally is right in front of you
and they're coughing and sneezing the
virus all over you that you can get sick
you still can so all those other rules
still apply covering your face when
you're out of the water washing your
hands
especially after you touch ladders
doorknobs and all the other public
surfaces and finally keeping six feet
away from others in or out of the water
what about the beach everyone wants to
go to the beach and I think the first
thing you have to do is check local and
state restrictions every Beach has
different rules and that's because
different areas are in different stages
of this pandemic certain areas have
already seen their peak and are dropping
down other areas are hitting all-time
highs so those two beaches will have
different rules and different
implications the one thing that works
for everybody is six feet away from
others no matter if you're swimming or
on land making sure your face is covered
when you're out of the water please
don't get your masks wet because if you
do they become useless and they actually
cause other problems actually a good
recommendation here would be potentially
to bring two masks with your two face
coverings and finally remembering to
wash your hands frequently as a side
note don't forget your SPF I actually
received a lot of questions from my
patients about whether or not the Sun
will actually kill the virus on the
beach and there is some sliver of truth
to this meaning that the virus does live
a shorter period outdoors where the
sun's UV rays are there but it's not a
natural disinfectant to the degree where
if someone sneezes it automatically gets
killed it's not that strong it's just a
shorter lifespan not a complete
elimination what about vacations well
first things first if you or someone in
your family member that's going to be
traveling is considered high-risk over
the age of 60 have an immunocompromised
state have several medical conditions I
think travel is an unnecessary risk at
this time that being said you can have
high-risk travel and low-risk travel and
to me if I'm gonna make a recommendation
to you as a doctor I'm gonna recommend
low-risk travel try going camping in a
remote area rent a home instead of
staying in a hotel if you're gonna stay
in a hotel stay on the first floor so
you don't need to be in an elevator with
a group of people or it may be
potentially take the stairs if you are
in a hotel on a higher floor remember
the biggest risks to your health is
exposure to lots of people
for significant period of time if you
can lower the amount of people you're
running into and spend less time with
them you're going to decrease the risk
that you're facing with Kovan 18
the same time if you're otherwise
healthy and you're following all
protocols covering your face washing
your hands keeping six feet away from
others when applicable and you get sick
with Cova 1992 95 percent of people will
be ok I don't want you to worry about
this where it's gonna cause you anxiety
remember my motto from the beginning of
this pandemic stay alert not anxious
what about restaurants if you see your
local restaurants beginning to open up
do not be afraid to call ahead or once
you get there to ask them what they're
going to be doing to keep you and your
family safe if they're not comfortable
answering that question feel free to
move on and go to another establishment
just like restaurants are required to
answer your questions about food
allergies they should be comfortable
discussing Kovan 19 safety practices
what about salons well again everyone
decides what risk is okay for them but I
will say if you're going for a hair
color versus a haircut I would consider
the hair color a riskier procedure not
because of its inherent nature of what
they're doing but simply because it
takes a longer period of time so you're
increasing your exposure to potentially
sick individuals we don't know who's
sick remember there's a lot of people
walking around who look just fine have
no symptoms and can potentially be
spreading this virus
what about theme parks while all their
regular rules six-feet masks hand
sanitizer all of that still applies but
a piece of advice for theme parks is to
avoid crowded areas if there's a long
line somewhere if there's a big group of
people try and stay away from that area
those are the areas where the virus
spreads quickly remember that Cova 19
spreads two to three times more rapidly
than influenza the last question and
probably the most important questions
that folks have been asking me is where
will America stand at the end of summer
and I think the answer of that question
relies heavily on you and me there's
really a level of personal
responsibility here if we open America
strategically and smartly and continue
monitoring our hospital systems and
follow all the guidelines that we've
been talking about six foot rule wearing
masks washing our hands frequently we
can be in a really good place this
summer to prepare for the fall flu
season but if we don't and we do
everything happen
we could potentially see another spike
that can cost us thousands of lives
unnecessarily fYI I'm gonna be doning
all of the Adsense revenue and matching
it to the Southern Poverty Law Center so
share this video with your friends and
family as these covet 19 tips can
potentially save someone's life and
definitely check out this educational
moving motivational speech by killer
Mike right here click it and as always
stay happy and healthy
[Music]